athletes and non-profit organizations  are teaming up to raise awareness about  social justice  earlier this morning nba player stephen  jackson hosted a community food donation  event  this campaign is traveling across the  country working not just to help pack  and provide weeks of meal bags  but to discuss issues like food  insecurity and racial justice  i want to continue to to show other  people and to be the face of all  athletes i have to be the face of  equality to show people that  not only when you black and proud that  does not mean that you have to hate the  next race  lack of prominence but you're  unstoppable that you can love everyone  but still  fight and do whatever you have to do and  nobody can stop you from reaching your  goals and reaching your dreams  the group says that each stop they will  provide approximately 1200 families with  boxes of fresh fruit vegetables  and pantry items